Heat.
[music]
Alhamdulillah.
you with Islamic greetings.
of this da'wah training program.
Alhamdulillah.
And as was mentioned earlier
mentioned earlier
absession of what was done the previous
day. So inshallah let's begin. Let us
set the ball rolling
with whom do you want me to start with
yamin?
Yes brother zag. Let's begin with
youalamlaykum.
>> They say in the morning we began with
the different sources and materials we
can refer to gain more Islamic knowledge
or where we can get more information for
doing dawa. And we learned the different
types of the and we learned the
different types of the translation of
the Quran. the different types of the se
of prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and many various books
alhamdulillah oceans of books and I
thank Dr. Zak for providing uh around 25
books he provided us with. Alhamdulillah
that's very great. Uh I thank him and
later after that we discussed the forms
of dawa means how dawa can be done in
different forms for example the print
media the audio media the video media
and many more.
And uh the the most interesting
thing which we learned yesterday like it
was the last session we learned how
[snorts] a thai when he speaks when he
answers how crystal clear he should be
in his words.
He should not say vague sentences or
vague words. This is very helpful
because in the future when you are asked
difficult questions so if you say a
vague answer a vague word you may be
trapped by it. So a dai whenever he says
something about Islam or gives his
review he should be crystal clear so
that he does not get trapped and he bees
on the safer side. That is the most
important thing we learn. This is one of
the characteristics of adai that he
should be crystal clear whenever he
conveys anything whether it be his views
or about Islam or he answers. that
mashallah you summarized the sessions
that which we had on the day two of this
international dawa training program but
as you said it brother Arsh that you
should be very careful but let me
correct you twice you said yesterday but
our session was the day before yesterday
I haven't come to the yesterday yet
inshallah yesterday was the rest day
along with the homework so inshallah
next time I hope that dies inshallah are
very careful about what they say
inshallah
who is next. Let's go to brother Shafi.
Brother Shafi since brother Arsh has
already covered
the day two and summarized it for all of
us present here like what sessions we
had. Let me ask you about yesterday
actual yesterday you were supposed to be
at your hotel rest as well as do your
homework. So first let me ask you how
many hours did you sleep for? The
previous night and the night before.
>> Previous night. Let me try to recall.
Inshallah.
>> Very precise as brother Ar said crystal
clear.
>> Previous night I think around inshallah
if I go to bed around 12 and then wake
up 5
or is it 6:00. So it's quite 12.
>> I asked you how many hours did you
sleep? I didn't ask the time. 4 5
>> 12 to 6.
>> 12 to 6. 6 hours.
>> 6 hours. Mashallah. And the night
before.
>> The night before. Hey, wait. This is the
night before. Not last night.
>> No, the night before the previous night.
>> The night.
>> Night before. The last night.
>> Which date is that?
>> The day was Sunday night.
You forgot.
>> Same.
>> The same. Mashallah. Have you prepared
for your homework today?
All the 50 suras with the names and the
meanings and 12 sets of verses of common
Quranic verses for dawa talks. 14 sets
of verses for most common questions
asked by non-Muslims about Islam.
Inshallah
>> I've not heard inshallah.
>> Inshallah. Inshallah.
>> D should be confident even if he doesn't
know the answer. First thing is
inshallah. I'll try my best.
Inshallah. Inshallah. Zakah. And did you
find any difficulties in learning the
surah names? Uh in the surah names is
quite okay. But the the main the most
difficult is to remember the the surah
the the surah the ayat in Arabic and
then in English and together with the
reference. And then what happened was
because there's so many things and we
are not like I personally I have not
been trained to how to memorize like I
don't know which one to memorize first.
So what I did was I tried to read all of
them and try to memorize. So that left
me when I tried to memorize the first 12
sets and I went to the second set is
that I have the cookies from all the
first 12 sets but I cannot nail that. I
cannot really recall 100% but it's all
inside my head. And then this morning I
tried to ask a few brothers on how to
actually memorize it. So that's was my
difficulties with the homework.
>> But you actually went to the step three
of the formula of success. Did you
follow step one and step two?
>> Yeah.
>> Did you pray to Allah subhanaa tala?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Did you ask for Allah's help?
>> Yes.
>> If Allah helps you,
>> none can overcome.
>> None can overcome.
>> Yeah.
>> But if Allah forsakes you, there is none
besides him who can help you. So let the
believers put their trust in Allah.
>> Yes.
>> So you didn't follow step number one.
>> I did.
>> And step number two, jihad. Did you
strive?
>> I I strive in I strive.
>> Did you do all the three steps? The
first two are very important. Before
asking your friends, before talking to
your other colleagues and then getting
an idea about how to memorize, first ask
Allah.
>> Yes.
>> Pray to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala and
then strive. And then you can learn the
technique of how to memorize. Allah will
surely come.
>> I asked the technique to brother Ars
just this morning mean I've tried for
the past two days and then I'll try to
>> if Allah helps you then surely Allah
help you overcome all these
difficulties. Yeah.
>> If you strive inshallah pass on the mic
to brother atikalam
>> brother atik.
>> Yes.
>> I hope that you received your copy of
the Quran with the transliteration.
>> Yes I did yesterday evening. So you find
it easy now to inshallah learn the
Quranic verses?
>> Not really. It's uh very difficult to
register the Arabic
verses because I have not been reading
for like over two and a half decades. So
>> did you follow the formula of success?
>> Yes.
>> Inshallah did it help?
>> Uh yeah I strived very hard.
>> Alhamdulillah. No before striving
Allah's help. Did you pray to Allah
subhanaa tala?
>> Yes I did.
>> Alhamdulillah. So you realize that
inshallah if you ask for Allah's help
and you do jihad inshallah all
difficulties will become easy for you
inshallah.
>> Absolutely.
>> Inshallah.
Okay let's move on to the left side on
my shimal. Where to begin with? Brother
Koiro.
Brother Koiro.
How was your day yesterday?
>> Oh yesterday. Yesterday we had a
interview.
>> Okay.
>> From from your crew as well as
>> Hope everyone is enjoying the reality
show.
Is everyone enjoying it? Alhamdulillah.
Very good. Yes.
>> And so much study on this 50 verses of
the Quran.
>> Sorry. Surah. Suras. Yes. Memorizing the
name of the suras as well as this
memorization of the [clears throat] the
verses.
Did you follow the formula of success?
Inshallah. Yes. Alhamdulillah.
>> What did you find more difficult?
Learning the surah names with meanings
or the Quranic verses?
>> Of course. Uh to memorize Arabic
the verses and then meaning in English.
So just I follow your formula to divide
into pieces and step by step.
>> Okay. You want to reach the excellent
level. Mashallah. Look at brother Koiro
that I told you that there are different
levels of learning the Quranic verses
and the best is that you'll give the
reference then you quote part Arabic
part English part Arabic part English
and this is the excellent way of quoting
the Quranic verses during your talk and
that is what brother Kochiro has
followed mashallah alhamdulillah let us
test today inshallah you know there is a
saying in Hindi dut panapi you know we
would know how How much water is there
and how much milk? So inshallah in the
evening session you'll definitely know.
ill.
[music and singing]
Allah
[music]
Oh yeah.
[chanting]
[music]
All Allah